[Music]
in today's reporters notebook we're
looking at how selfless actions can
inspire all of us this week we've shared
stories about two men who embody those
qualities showing that service often
goes hand-in-hand with sacrifice Senator
John McCain a war hero has spent 35
years serving in Congress and former
President Jimmy Carter is still
volunteering with Habitat for Humanity
at age 93 envy is one of the seven
deadly sins advertisers use envy to push
us to buy products we don't need in
social media Envy carves out that hollow
feeling envy is to be avoided but this
week David Letterman introduced me to a
different kind of envy the envy that
leads to action his Envy for people who
made a difference in the world drew him
to Jimmy Carter and Habitat for Humanity
I should be thanking you for the last 14
years he's clipped on a tool belt and
swung a hammer building houses
he says it's changed his life you know
the first time we did it everybody came
up to me and said oh thank you well
thank you well thank you and I said
you're crazy you're crazy
thank you and you would you would get
that from any of these people in the
helmets building now they are indebted
to the President to Habitat for Humanity
giving them the opportunity to help
people because when you help others feel
better about yourself this is called
benign Envy the desire to be better when
we see someone doing something good this
was the underlying theme of many of the
tributes to Senator John McCain people
felt called to be their best because his
example drew people to as he used to say
serve a cause greater than their
self-interest tomorrow's memorial for
Senator McCain will perhaps stir the
kind of benign and V my mother used to
feel at funerals after hearing the
deceased described with words like
character and generosity and love she
would leave the funeral inspired to go
out and live her life that way so we
need more Envy in the world whether you
envy John McCain Jimmy Carter David
Letterman or MA the envy that leads to
action
not a sin but salvation oh I love that
John I love that it's a good trade it's
like a lot of these feelings that you
have sort of accepting them and
realizing if they drive you create
passion in you change your character for
the better that's good
yeah grant woods at McCain's service
yesterday said what people see in McCain
is what they want to go see in
themselves I do believe that doing good
gives you better more joy than buying
something yeah no let's all go out and
do something that's right